[Music]
begin with Jennifer Lawrence getting
real about her extreme diet before her
first nude scenes the red spire of star
went a raven black at last night's
premiere with Carly Steele
this is a badass dress thank you I'm the
badass smoothie way definitely can't
smile it's just like so not in the mood
for the dress so I just brought on the
red card for the section yes masking her
effortless sense of humor with an
oscar-worthy dramatic red-carpet pose
jave all draped into your health courts
at the New York premiere for red Sparrow
she says playing a ballerina was the
first time she has ever dies it for a
role and made sure to shoot the ballet
scenes first and I just you know would
want you know jack-in-the-box and just
eat you know chicken breasts so like
that to me is like I'm starving it was
tough once my character stopped doing
ballet it was done and I've never been
able to find that discipline everybody
go I can't do this for six months so
you'll see she starts coming back
Jennifer also graces the March cover of
Vanity Fair with a sultry shoot that
pays tribute to her Kentucky country
roots Jennifer I admit she was nervous
about shooting red sparrows nude scenes
after being so outspoken about intimate
photos being hacked from her phone in
2014 saying quote my biggest fear was
that people would say oh how can you
complain about the hack if you're going
to get nude anyway she filmed the scenes
in front of a crew that included many
alumni from The Hunger game franchise
who quotes new me since I was a baby
after the scenes wrapped she turned to
the camera team and said quote I hope
you guys feel creepy please welcome
Jennifer Lawrence leading up to the
premiere Jennifer made an appearance at
compare she threw back multiple shots of
rum kicked off her shoes and then gave
this unfiltered film review it's a
psychological spy drama I'm a woman but
it's not like you know like like if
you're like a typical hater and you have
a blog don't go
invite all my haters - goodness me red
sparrow I had two shots are all my
promise you well let me tell you
Jennifer Lawrence can hold her liquor
she did three rounds of vodka shots with
me when we sat down together and she
also told me they were doing vodka shots
in between takes while filming rents
Paris and Nancy this girl can hang
[Music]
you